and now a new peak of descendants - I
see no need to bring that into the ship
it may be a little unnecessary but oh it
is so much fun here's the do just like
your mother always a catch if you win
then free to go don't you want to know
what I can to find one still dreaming
let's have my check - your mother
thought she had things all sewn up - huh
how that won't happen again on three one
two three
you know shuttle Princesa
well I never bought it for a second you
could stick a CR all the villa but
there's still ability and you can slap a
pirate hat on but you're still shrimpy
[Music]
and if I win to bring you the wand
attendance - coming to Disney Channel
three days to the world cotillion how
does it feel to be the most envied girl
in Oregon everybody wants me to be this
lady of the court and have no idea how
to keep up the act don't you ever in
screaming at people and just making them
run away from you not really
this isn't the Isle of the Lost now
believe me I know that comeback style
I'm back that little traitor who grabbed
everything she wanted and left me
nothing when I give my chance to random
the evil on Oregon how I'll take it this
is my fault
I have to go there and apologize just
wait until emma is you're back where's
Ben I'm not capture him if you want
Beastie Boy bad bring me fairy
godmothers magic going on you better
hope your girlfriend comes through
you always were quite the drama queen
this is between you and me we've been
through a lot together not stopping that
now you could stick a tiara on a villain
but it's still a villain
losing not an option because we're
rotten to the core
take care by the way I know I'm like
loving it isn't like a lot later hello
[Music]
welcome to the abdomen Dodge
[Music]
I just Mitch we're here at this amazing
castle we're about to shoot ways to be
with you
[Music]
I'm working on tables or throwing papers
everywhere we've got all the way to give
you let me write ad our music you see
Samba side ordered on kids which was so
much fun for me so many questions we
nailed the biggest shot thank you
[Applause]
coming
you